we've got a series here called earth 365
that explores the health of our planet
365 days a year and today we are
focusing on something you probably
haven't thought a whole lot about we
hadn't until recently and that would be
cement new methods of making cement
could be a game changer in the fight
against climate change and that's
because if the cement industry as a
whole was a country unto itself it would
be the third largest emitter of
planetworm and carbon dioxide in the
world right after China and these United
States but now all that could change Ben
Tracy looks at the race to decarbonize
the building blocks of our world
it's the backbone of our buildings our
roads and our bridges and just about
every Dam thing in between
[Music]
cement is a powder that when mixed with
water forms concrete besides water it's
the most widely used substance on Earth
cement is the binder so that's the
sticky stuff that we put in concrete
what people always like to say is you
know it's not a cement truck it's a
concrete truck Cody Finke is the CEO of
Brimstone and if you want to know what
his team is attempting to do behind this
garage door in Oakland California well
the writing is on the wall it's really
nice to look at I think he and
co-founder Hugo leandry were Caltech
scientists who decided to tackle cement
while their fellow grad students focused
on electric vehicle batteries and solar
panels almost no one was working on
cement and that might be that cement is
not particularly sexy yeah it's pretty
gray and blocky yeah it doesn't look
high-tech
cement is a concrete problem the
industry is responsible for about eight
percent of Planet warming carbon dioxide
emissions that's about the same as every
passenger car on the road worldwide and
far more than the global carbon
emissions from Aviation
far in the whole guys far in the hope
most traditional cement is made from
Limestone blasted out of the side of
giant quarries like this one in
California's Mojave Desert
it's like The Flintstones come to life
yep
Steve Regis runs cement operations for
Cal Portland's Oro Grande cement plant
this is limestone Limestone contains
Calcium The Binding agent in cement but
Limestone also contains carbon dioxide
the main greenhouse gas rapidly warming
the planet now of course the CO2 up the
stack
is the obvious elephant in the room
it's up to the top of the plant just
watch your hard hat so it doesn't
to show us this giant Kiln that's really
the heart of the cement plant
where the limestone is super heated to
about 2700 degrees using these piles of
coal that process releases tons of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere this
stack is where the CO2 comes out correct
Regis argues that concrete is a
time-tested and reliable building
material and the industry is working to
make it cleaner but back at Brimstone
Cody Finke has discovered a potentially
game-changing yet shockingly simple
shortcut we're just making the same
thing from a different Rock
they are called calcium silicate rocks
and don't contain any Planet warming CO2
is there enough of your rock to go
around to really change this whole
industry it's about 200 times more
abundant than Limestone so it is
basically half of the rocks on the
surface of the Earth we can use and
thanks to Big backers including Bill
Gates's breakthrough energy Ventures and
Amazon's climate pledge Brimstone is
attempting to rapidly scale up its
Innovation claiming it will be cheaper
and just as reliable as traditional
cement if you haven't yet built a
building or a road or a bridge or
something out of this how do you know
it's as reliable as Limestone based
cement is because it is chemically and
physically identical we're quite
confident that the chemistry works and
we can make the same material and if he
can convince the global construction
industry this is cement and there's no
CO2 in this right it could become the
building block of a cleaner future for
CBS mornings I'm Ben Tracy in Oak
Oakland California
thank you Ben Tracy